[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show I
am still waiting for polling that will
tell us how did that very poor
performance by Michael Bloomberg last
week affect his support but also how did
it affect Elizabeth Warren's support
because Elizabeth Warren got a lot a lot
of attention as being sort of the most
aggressive prosecutor really of Michael
Bloomberg's kind of failed explanations
about non-disclosure agreements and
women who had made complaints about
either things he had said or done or
things that are done by others at his
companies and a couple of days after the
debate Michael Bloomberg announced on
Twitter that they were only able to
identify I guess supposedly three NDA's
that were relevant to the discussion at
the debate but even that is a little bit
dicey Pat because the wording of how he
said we've identified three that relate
to it was sort of something like things
he said there's a whole bunch that could
relate to things he's done I mean the
way it was worded really didn't tell us
very much about what went on yeah I'm
surprised we got this news at all though
you'd think that Michael Bloomberg would
want to make this all just go away yeah
it was pretty clear on the debate stage
last week that he wasn't prepared for a
question about this or you know being
attacked by another candidate about this
stuff because you could just see he was
trying to find the words he was trying
to come up with what to say he certainly
wasn't going to release the women from
the non-disclosure agreements there that
night on the debate stage but to see his
campaign scramble and try to deal with
they try to like deal with the disaster
that was his debate performance last
week I've been enjoying it personally
now case in point I actually did just
pull up we do have one poll from
post-debate and in that poll Bloomberg
is down to 13 down a couple of points
but Warren is up to 19 in this the only
post debate poll we have so far now one
poll doesn't tell us anything if three
more polls come out in warrens at 19
then we might have something to talk
about
but imagine if Elizabeth Warren really
does get nearly a six or seven point
boost from this that would be incredible
well two things one after the debate
performance Michael Bloomberg's odds at
winning the nomination like the Vegas
odds
yes actually putting money into the
auction throws just tanked yeah they
tanked after his debate because he had
just such a terrible performance and you
know I'm surprised that Warren got a
significant uptick from her debate
performance because what we've seen in
the past is when one candidate takes
down another candidate it's not
necessarily good for the winning
candidate in that exchange like an
example that comes to mind is in 2016
when chris christie called out marco
rubio for repeating the same talking
points rubio seems to have malfunctioned
he became a robot definitely that tanks
Rubio's campaign that was probably what
stuck a fork in it but it's not like
christie sir Jeff now that support
actually went to Trump and other
candidates as well well the one bit of
data that correlates with Elizabeth
Warren doing well in the one post debate
poll is that she apparently also raised
some record amount of money for her
campaign in the 48 hours following the
debate so we'll see we'll see as we get
more more polling data but in the
meantime Elizabeth Warren was asked
Bloomberg said they only identified
three NDA's he's willing to release the
women from them what do you think and
Elizabeth Warren is in short saying it's
just not nearly enough it's too little
too late it doesn't really do much and I
tend to agree that at this point it's
really all posturing none of this
changes who one believes Michael
Bloomberg fundamentally is but is it
possible that this could totally
backfire like I mean I'm sure the
Bloomberg team when they're deciding who
to release from NDA's they know exactly
what could come out yeah but maybe
they're you know maybe that's a risky
hand that they're playing because if
these women are released from these
non-disclosure agreements and then they
say exactly what Michael Bloomberg said
or did to them that could be disastrous
for his campaign yeah if more comments
like horse-faced lesbian come to light
that i don't know that that's a term you
necessarily want associated with things
you've said if you're running a
presidential campaign on the Democratic
side on the Republican side it almost
seems it would guarantee a nomination
but that we're not we're talking about a
guy who is at least ostensibly a
Democrat as of today is what we can say
about Michael Bloomberg and some people
thought it was unprecedented for a
presidential candidate to talk about
horseface lesbians and fat
ra's on the debate stage but remember in
2016 the Republicans were talking about
their penis size on the debate stage so
nothing is unprecedented
yeah and Trump's comments about women
some dog like who dog related comments
about women or maybe Rosie Oh something
about Rosie O'Donnell yeah like that
anyway we'll see how it continues one
poll so far shows a slight down downturn
for Bloomberg big uptick for Warren and
we'll see how it continues a daredevil
who espoused flat earth conspiracy
theories has died after falling from a
homemade rocket we've covered some of
these guys before who planned to prove
that the earth is actually flat by
flying up on a rocket to see if they can
perceive the curvature of the earth and
of course this is all crazy in that if
you don't fly up high enough you
wouldn't perceive the curvature of the
earth anyway you wouldn't really prove
anything it's incredibly dangerous
homemade rocket making is very very
dangerous and mad Mike Hughes a former
limo driver was attempting to launch
himself 5000 feet into the air on a
steam-powered rocket the parachute
tragically failed and it rips off just
after launch Hughes falls through the
air crashes to the ground people gasp
and he did he did tragically die now I
don't find the death any less tragic
because he was a flat earther I just
think there's too much of people who
don't know anything getting themselves
into dangerous situations like the Flat
Earth part it sort of neither here nor
there
in terms of the tragic nature of the
death from somebody who is doing
something they were woefully under
qualified for well here's an interesting
angle to this so we've covered this guy
specifically before and yes daredevil
stunts and we've always wondered like
how exactly is going up in the sky and a
rocket going to be able to prove to
everyone that the world is flat even if
you you know yourself think that you're
real - you're able to see it just by
looking at it and observing the lack of
curvature and the earth that's not
necessarily going to be proof for other
people because you're not exactly
documenting it yeah like we always had
these questions about this and it turns
out that the Flat Earth are conspiracy
theories touted by this guy May
just been a way to get the message out
that he was doing these stunts and you
know he's been a daredevil for years and
years so maybe it was just a way for him
to get publicity to like hi it to a Flat
Earth theory and that's what gave him
some notoriety certainly some popularity
within the Flat Earth movement but it's
entirely possible that this guy wasn't
actually a flat earther and was just
looking for a good PR stunt yeah his PR
person is saying we used flat earthers
PR and again the guy had been asked
several times do you believe the earth
is shaped like a frisbee and he said I
believe it is but I don't know for sure
who knows what he really believed but I
guess this is yet another data point
that tells us amateur rocket travel is
serious business and don't do it because
you could end up dead and this guy did
and now listen if you're this guy's
family this is horribly tragic what else
can we say yeah definitely horribly
tragic but you know if he was a
daredevil his whole life this is I'm
sure the type of thing that he loved
doing and so you know it's a type of
thing that can certainly happen I don't
know if are you willing to score this as
a as one for the spherical earth side I
mean it anyway disprove the Flat Earth
theory the fact that this mission failed
this does nothing one way or the other
this just proves this guy did something
extremely dangerous regardless of his
beliefs about the shape of the planet
this doesn't do one thing that's the I
mean no matter what side you're on of
the Flat Earth debate to the extent that
it is a debate and I don't believe that
it is there are no winners or losers
here I think we can safely say oh one
more thing I mean if you really did this
to prove that the earth was flat
couldíve just attached a GoPro to the
rocket would lose them and okay why just
getting that in there why does he need
to go up he could have just sent the
camera up I think that that's absolutely
and perfectly reasonable the supreme
court agreed today to hear an appeal by
a catholic foster agency which says they
are in danger of losing their government
contract because they refused to recruit
or certify same-sex couples as potential
foster parents we talked in June of 2015
when the Supreme Court decided that
states banning same-sex marriage would
no longer be allowed we all knew that
the new
battle will be religious liberty along a
few different fronts do you or do not
have to bake a cake for a gay wedding
right that was one big data point up
firing people for their real or
perceived sexual orientation and what
about religious employers and so on and
so forth a gay adoption is another one
and for better or worse there are a lot
of foster agencies and adoption agencies
that are tied in with we could say
churches in general but it's often
Catholic churches Catholic Charities
that are involved they don't want to
send foster kids into same-sex couple
homes they don't want to let children be
adopted by same-sex parents and this is
now going to go to the Supreme Court
this is going to be after the notable
replacement of Anthony Kennedy by Brett
Kavanaugh this matters if there was ever
the need for one additional data point
about why we would have been at better
off with Hillary Clinton why I believe
even Michael Bloomberg would be better
than from Bloomberg would not put Brett
Kavanaugh on the court right we now have
a court where the swing vote from
Anthony Kennedy who was often with the
left on LGBT issues often with the right
or the establishment on more corporate
issues but Kennedy was often with the
left on LGBT issues he's gone Kavanagh
now is there and we'll wait and see what
happens but it could be another one of
these disasters yeah and how is this
going to be any good for kids in foster
homes I mean there's 400,000 children
all across the country currently in
foster care and you know oftentimes it's
hard to find the sponsors for families
for them to go to and this just you know
reduces the number of people who could
possibly adopt them if you're just going
to cut away the same-sex married couples
and so yeah I mean this is something
that could have major implications I
think that the Supreme Court took up
this case a few years ago with Kennedy
on the court they probably would have
ruled against the so-called religious
liberty side but now it's it's probably
likely that they will route the the
conservatives will win this and again
what's really at issue here is the
government contract right yes at this
point it there are men
religiously affiliated foster agencies
that don't have a government contract
and for now it is legal in most states
for them to say we don't foster out to
same-sex parent households the question
is can their government contract be
taken away for that reason and that's
really what's at issue here and I tend
to lean in your direction Pat I think
it's at least very plausible that the
court is going to find with the Catholic
charity that does not want same-sex
couple fostering and it is very very sad
and unfortunately there you know it's
important to remember I always think
it's important to have a realistic
assessment of where we are on any issue
right so when same-sex marriage became
legal eyes nationally de facto by the
2015 decision that was huge progress
that was really great there's a lot of
heterosexual couples that don't care
about marriage there's a lot of LGBT
couples that don't care about marriage
but the right to marry should be the
same and it was made so in 2015 great
that was in advance but we still have
very very far to go particularly on this
issue of being able to be fired in so
many states for your real or perceived
sexual orientation this is another issue
the adoption foster care issue so we've
made progress we've got a way to go a
lot of money is still raised in
evangelical circles on these issues
that's where we are today what else can
we say yeah I think that about does it
it just goes to show that elections do
have consequences and there are a lot of
people who were not interested in voting
for Hillary Clinton over Donald Trump
because maybe they supported Bernie
Sanders or they didn't like the two
candidates but yeah as you said before
if Hillary was president this certainly
would not be going this way and it makes
me think you know with this election
coming up in 2020 certainly Bernie has a
good shot at winning the Democratic
nomination but if it's someone like
Bloomberg who many people on the Left
will not be very excited to vote for
will they be able to put those
differences aside and just suck it up
and vote for him because the alternative
is going to be so much worse and we'll
see what happens with that stuff
I also by the way I don't want to open
up a can of worms I'm being careful
about saying this on the regular show I
really doubt that anyone is going to
beat Trump I really do and I know that
what I'm saying is it shouldn't be
controversial because when you look at
the betting numbers the most likely
single scenario is a trump reelection
still in just about every betting
related thing if I talk about it too
much on the Regular Show people get
angry they say I'm being defeatist they
say I'm deflating the troops you know my
thing has always been to just say things
the way I see them and and let's let's
hope I'm wrong but I really question
whether anybody is going to beat Donald
Trump this time around personally right
now looking at the numbers I think that
if Bernie Sanders is the nominee he
would be the favorite to beat Trump
overall because we don't know who the
Democratic nominee is right now I would
say the Trump is the favorite of course
Wow and also what's really concerning is
if you look at some of the swing states
right now it looks like Ohio is just
solidly in the hands of Republicans like
it's going to be tough for Democrats to
win back Ohio and Wisconsin yeah no one
even thought would be a swing state back
in 2016 it was a total shock when Trump
won Wisconsin he's now leading there
against every potential candidate
leading there yes and that's why I like
five six points so yeah I mean it would
be a struggle to win back Wisconsin of
course the Democrats have their
convention there in July but it may not
be enough to win that stay back in
listen yeah I saw that same polling if
Trump wins Ohio and Wisconsin
I don't know how Democrats win I mean I
I know that mathematically it's possible
right like you can lose Ohio in
Wisconsin to trump and then as long as
you get Michigan back and you win
Pennsylvania and you win Florida like
mathematically you can do it but if
Wisconsin is going to trump by five it's
very likely that a lot of other things
are going wrong so I saw that polling
and it was it was disturbing to say the
least yeah and then if Bernie Sanders is
the nominee can he win in Florida
because you know I know Florida has been
trending more and more Republican and
also if you have someone who calls
himself a Democratic Socialist how is
that going to play among the Cuban
population in Florida yeah would they
choose someone in Sanders over Trump so
I mean I think Florida would be a key
state to watch too because that's just
such a massive state I mean even if
Trump is able to sweep the Rust Belt if
Democrats pick up Florida that would be
probably enough to put him over the edge
it's gonna be it's gonna be a crazy next
eight months that's for sure um thanks
to everybody for joining me tomorrow new
show
new bonus show and debate stream we will
have a pre debate show on YouTube twitch
and Facebook and then we will be doing
the debate itself on Twitch tomorrow
Tuesday night I have no clue when the
debate starts but once we figure once I
hit that out o'clock I think if it's 8
o'clock p.m. Eastern I'll be starting at
7:15 if it's 9 o'clock p.m. Eastern I'll
be starting 45 minutes before the debate
I will be starting I will see you then
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]